well uh Denzel called me on a friday i
think it wasn't he he said your your
about the equalizer i said yeah i heard
they were developing something for you
for that he said you know the TV show i
said my mother my grandmother knew more
than me but I've seen it a few times he
goes well we have a script I want to get
it to you I think you'd be perfect for
it if you're available so I was a pretty
sure I be available for me but actually
I was going to do southpaw first and
when I'm editing now with jake
gyllenhaal and and I read it and I could
to see Denzel playing that role and so I
called him i said i love it i want to do
it but i got a flat in new york and see
Harvey Weinstein because Harvey has
South Pole and I gotta send out with the
Godfather and tell Harvey I need to go
through this with you and hold that for
me for a year and he said yes he did his
credit Harvey said absolutely I get a un
Denzel together go do it I'll hold it
and he did because one thing that I've
admired about your films they the
characters always the character has this
sense of or this character in particular
as they innate sense of justice to me
the action has to be informative and
that's normally where I'd start with it
so I look at the action scenes as the
dialogue scene I look at the action
scenes what is it saying to you was it
tell you about the character as opposed
to exposition it's another as motion
pictures right so what can I say with
the action is seen so in this case with
Denzel rubber McCall he was a very quiet
complex character and I shot it that way
very slow i stalked him a lot from
behind I creep down hallways coming
around corners and it was always about
discovering of the other man discovery
of the man shoot through glass and
things like that and so when we got into
the room with the Russians the concept
there was to shoot it like a dialogue
scene so that my camera became another
character in the fight and I wanted to
make sure that you saw the violence
clearly to see him doing the violence
because they're still acting going on in
his eyes so to shake the camera around
and do all this fancy stuff you lose
drama you lose the impact of the
violence because the violence tells you
a little bit about his past the way he
does it it tells you that how do you
learn to do that what type of
individuals do that and the reason why I
went into his eye and all these things
was because I did research when I read
the script you know it's like the
classic the Indians attacked the fort is
like and then something amazing happens
in the room he kills everybody knows I
ok the directors problem right said
Richard wake with his lab he goes to
figure that one out so it said some sort
of vision he had so I started talking to
some doctors my friends of mine that are
doctors and in a couple buddies or Navy
SEALs and m1 individuals like it just
does black off work and I literally told
Richard come to my house I'm going to
bring some of my buddies one of them in
particular Paul came over my wife died
there she's like you guys are nuts and
he came down into my theater in he
brought a bag of things and I say here's
the scenario we discussed it he read the
pages he said well you know in these
sort of situation these are the sort of
things that I would be looking for right
away in the room if I'm if I know I'm
coming in the room and violence as a
possibility he would know things in the
room that he can use as weapons you know
I mean from from a lag chair of our
lecture being broken it would become a
weapon two corkscrews shotgun glasses
all these different things and Keith
Keith Bullard is a stunt coordinator
he's a Navy SEAL so we have the human
anatomy we would discuss where the soft
spots were and what kind of trauma that
would create also when i spoke to
doctors and I with the eye doctors and I
said what happens when the body is
excited when you know and one of the
doctors was explaining to me that these
particular individuals are trained for
their body for their hearts to go down
they're trained to find comfort and
chaos you know the pupils open up for
more light to get in so things become
more vivid and sharp and for them it
happens that quick for us you know a
bomb goes off or even allow bang in the
back we're all going to jump they go
towards it there's a different type of
individual that's part of training over
and over and over so I said how do you
show that so I said well you
to go and do it from the inside out so
it's more or less from his perspective
and in sound helps and so it became more
informative scene of this type of
individual and what's happening inside
of him and then how brutal he can
actually be you know there's violent men
and there's men at understand violence
he understands violence that's why I
doesn't want to have anything to do with
it really because you know there's no
end to it until people are dead and
that's why says I'm sorry I mean he's
coming he's coming he's come home
afflicted conflicted because of his wife
right yeah raishin how do you give
Denzel Washington direction it yeah I
mean everybody needs direction right
that's what he counseled actually he's a
trust is a big deal with me and Denzel
um when I did training day I did a scene
and I got the shot I was feeling good
about I say no until you want to come
but I was nervous training day was my
third movie I'm with Denzel Washington
anything honk like you want to come over
and see the monitor and you know make
sure you're good with it before I move
on he said no I mean you're flying this
plane you know the time to be afraid is
when planes on the ground let me know
when you need me walked away and I was
thinking I cannot screw this up you know
but he's never ever looked at the
monitor and he's never questioned the
things I asked him to do he'll ask
obvious if a logical thing to try to
understand and get in my head a little
bit and and sometimes I don't give it
all away because he's already doing some
things I don't want it to become a I
wanted to just keep doing what he's
doing but you know you just talked to
him like you would with any actor and
he's an actor Denzel will tell you
himself he's an actor first when the
movies over he's an unemployed actor
right you know and he wants to be
handled that way and he trusts you he
trusts me and and his he has to happen
and we collaborate and we spent a lot of
time together before man we have fun we
locked the door we talked we he came up
with the OCD and we talked about shaving
his head and I was young my head may
have inspired him but you know it's like
and we started just we just kind of play
with the same thing with training day
and we just designed it we talked about
the character and we go deeper as weak
as we can and then we both agree that's
what we're doing
we just go to work